je sais plus sur vercingétorix que sur
mes parents j'en sais plus sur clovis et
son [ __ ] de base que sur mon père et
la guerre d'algérie
[Musique]
derrière les images d'épinal de notre
passé il ya une autre histoire
il faut rajouter nous aussi parce qu'on
va en faire partie de l'histoire on en
fait partie de l'histoire
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
pourquoi j'ai voulu faire parce que le
sujet me touche et grave moi dans vous
souvenez ce documentaire il me rappelait
pas ils ne montraient pas en exemple
j'ai des gt gt un exemple parmi tant
d'autres c'est ça qui m'intéressait
on
[Musique]
mes parents sont arrivés en 60 de mon
père avant 62 après la guerre d'algérie
où mon père quand il ya des bus en
algérie et coller la ratp
embauché en france beaucoup donc mon
père est venu des joies des mamans et ce
toute cette génération nos parents qui
sont que les way non ça n'arrive pas ça
je suis pas j'ai encore du mal ça parce
que c'est une génération qui est parti
qui par leurs enfants ça a été dur pour
eux france et qu'on allait mettre nos
parents dans des cités et en banlieue
le temps de reconstruire la france une
fois que la france serait reconstruite
et qu'elle serait une grande puissance
économique et industriel comme elle est
la cinquième même je crois je pensais
que là ça y est on allé casser les
banlieues et au moins accepter les
enfants de ces gens là qui sont saignés
et leur ouvrir les portes et non pas du
tout celle inverse qui est arrivé est
d'ailleurs tout est dans l'étymologie du
mot banlieue bon mètre au banc et lieu à
au moins une lieux de la ville c'est une
volonté de mettre les gens là bas il ya
même un mot pour ça j'adore regarder les
reportages à la télé les docks sur nos
ancêtres les gaulois j'adore ça j'ai
appris comment sont nés les parisiens
d'où ils venaient j'adore l'histoire
c'est génial les girondins les jacobins
révolution ceci c'est génial c'est super
il faut pas enlever ça enfin on va sinon
on va prendre quelle histoire
mais il faut rajouter nous aussi parce
que voilà on faire partie de l'histoire
on en fait partie du soir mais il faut
pas il faut juste nous rajouter c'est ce
qu'on demande depuis le début du fond de
nos cités il faut juste nous rajouter
c'est tout
[Musique]
98 points l'âge d'or des arabes en
france c'est la meilleure période pour
les arabes au monde
j'ai vu des cailleras prendre des crs
dans les bras je vais jamais vu ça de
moi ce que je vois surtout c'est que
donc depuis 98 et depuis bien avant le
point commun de tous ces gamins c'est
qu'ils disent mais nous on est français
c'est comme avoir quelqu'un qui dit je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime et vous
l'écoutez pas